In 1894, Milton Hershey had an idea:...
...make chocolate, which was a luxury for the rich, affordable for the masses.
By 1909, Hershey Chocolate Company was the largest confectionery company in the US...
...and dominated market share.
But through the years,...
...there's been increasing doubt about the ability of chocolate alone...
...to support the Hershey Company.
After half a century of being the only chocolate player in town,...
...Mars became a tough competitor.
The owner of M&M and Snickers forced Hershey...
...to finally create a marketing department in the 1960s.
There have also been  ebbs and flows and concerns about chocolate itself.
Fears about caffeine led Hershey to build its tech center that still exists today.
Hershey has, over the years, tried to buffer these risks.
It's bought or owned Friendly's Ice Cream parlors, pasta, cookies, bars and nuts.
None stuck.
It considered buying Cadbury in England, but it was too expensive.